The Witcher producer Comes Out Swinging
as if he's getting a fifth season
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
in case you've been out of the country
on mars or living under a rock and you
haven't heard Henry Cavill is leaving
his role of geralt of Rivia yeah
Gerald
geralt and Liam Hemsworth is taking up
the role
now I'm going to talk about what I think
about Liam Hemsworth in a minute in that
role it's like ordering a pie and
finding it has no filling
but first of all I'm going to tell you
what Thomas baginski has been saying
today in an interview He Has Come Out
Swinging Henny has been making
suggestions that
a changing actor might be a great thing
for the series that actually losing
Henry Cavill isn't a major problem and
bringing in a completely new actor is
just the norm not a problem at all well
I'm gonna argue in a minute it is a
problem but for now let's think about
what he actually said he compared the
role of The Witcher to James Bond or
Doctor Who that's
true he suggested that a new actor can
bring something new and exciting to the
role something that has happened over
and over again with Doctor Who sometimes
for Success David Tennant sometimes not
so much
and just like that with James Bond that
when they create a new iteration of the
character they change a little bit
mixing up a little bit now he's
suggesting that Liam Hemsworth is going
to do the same with the character of
geralt of Rivia and that this could
actually be a good thing in the long run
for the series
now I am going to point out the bloody
obvious it isn't and it won't
it doesn't rhyme
for good predictions rhyme
unfortunately Henry Cavill had made that
character his own he is a massive geek
he loved the character and he put his
all into it I am sorry but Liam
Hemsworth even though he's an actor I
quite like and when the rumor was
knocking around that he was maybe going
to take on the Stargate role until he
managed to talk himself out of it by
being greedy the idiot and he decided to
go this way instead mainly because
Netflix gave him everything he was
asking for
I actually thought that for Stargate he
would be perfect but for The Witcher
there's no Henry Cavill he's not even as
good as his brother for God's sake so
why does he think he can take this role
I'm going to tell you straight away or
I've got a few problems with this
now when Henry Cavill actually took this
role you know how he talks very
subjective very deep and very remember I
actually didn't like that at first I
actually it actually took me probably
two or three episodes of the first
season to get used to what Henry Cavill
was doing with the role
he was playing it like the character he
was actually really really good in it
but it did take a little while to get
used to because it was quite unusual
what happened with you you [ __ ]
goat
but now I am used to it I think
completely fell in love with what he was
doing and by the end of the first series
I was a complete Witcher nut Liam
Hemsworth now the problem is he's going
to be tempted to do a impression
basically of Henry Cavill he's going to
do an impression of what Henry Cavill
was doing with the character
I think that's going to be a massive
problem because I don't think Liam
Hemsworth has the stage presence or just
the Charisma that Henry cavill's got
he's not got the same voice he's not got
the same mannerisms he's not as big he's
not his imposing a human being even
though he is as I say not a little fella
so I think if they've got any sense they
will move away from him doing an
impression of Henry Cavill and instead
they will try to go a slightly different
direction now that is
incredibly dangerous because this is
actually a very very popular show and a
very loved character and obviously a
very loved actor this is why the DC have
begged him to return to Superman because
he is perfect for that role as he is
perfect for The Witcher
now there's been lots of rumors about
why Henry Cavill is actually moving away
from The Witcher one of them being that
he just doesn't get on with producers
like Tom Ash baginski that they've been
trying to bring the character away from
Canon for a little while and trying to
do something different with it he also
has apparently according to sources I
speak to complained about the
sexualization of the show and felt that
it has at times gone too far he thinks
they've done a HBO version of this
trying to compete with things like
character of the Dragon instead of doing
something that's actually legitimate and
really based in the existing Canon now I
I can't say if that's 100 fact
um it's just opinion that I've been told
by somebody that works in the field
that's heard or Whispers around the
campfire but it does kind of sound like
Henry Cavill to be honest as I say he's
a massive geek for this he knows these
stories inside and out and he is
actually quite a naturally quite a
subdued character he is a nerd he likes
building computers and things like this
go and look it on YouTube he doesn't
tend to do roles that are particularly
sexualized and things he doesn't tend to
do roles at a particularly risky he is
quite a quiet man himself and I think
that shows in some of his other work and
I can understand and maybe believe that
actually some of the stuff that goes on
The Witcher goes against the sort of
person he is and maybe that has left a
bit of taste in his mouth at times I
honestly believe though the main reason
for him stepping away from The Witcher
is that DC have come begging for him to
return to Superman he's going to be very
very busy in the DC Universe over the
next few years and Superman a character
he's been talking about today is
something he is very excited to take in
a slightly different direction and more
wholesome more fun Direction
so can Liam Hemsworth meet expectations
whatever happens season 4 of The Witcher
when Liam Hemsworth takes over is going
to see a quite substantial dip in
viewing figures but if the show is good
a loyal fan base will stay a loyal fan
base will give it a try if the show
continues to be good continues along the
vein it has till now those fans will
stick with it and By Word of Mouth the
fans might return and they will watch
this show eventually but it is gonna
have to be really good and I actually
think
Liam's Hemsworth on this one is going to
have to go in a different direction he
can't do an impression of Henry Cavill
and if he does it will bomb he's going
to have to try to do something a little
bit different with this and that's the
risk because it's going to piss a lot of
people off when he does but hand on
heart it's the only way in the long run
the show can survive
if we get a season five of The Witcher I
would be genuinely shocked I would give
it maybe 20 chance which is all I can
hope for you good Lords at your final
breath
a shitless death
but if we do it'll be because Liam's
Hemsworth and the producers directors
Etc and the writers have been pretty
brave with it as I say if they aren't
Brave it will bomb terribly so guys get
in the comment section what you think is
The Witcher dead after season four now
we know this is on Netflix so they will
at least do the season it won't be
canceled halfway through but will we
ever get to see a season five
personally I very much doubt it but
that's not really what matters what do
you think get in the comments if you are
new to the channel don't forget to like
subscribe to that Bell notification so
you don't miss any of our new videos
also go over to sidetrix sides our
sister Channel where I do the best bits
from all the live shows I also do little
videos about other things other than
sci-fi and coming up really soon I'm
going to do some videos on Mysteries and
stuff so going in a little bit of a
different direction with that it'll be a
lot of fun as always guys please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
thank you